I'm from Germany
nice to meet you they're off on a new
adventure
everyone in this tour group has already
seen Sugarloaf and the Statue of Christ
today they're visiting one of Rio de
Janeiro's favelas the excursion costs 40
euros apiece I chose to travel on a tour
of this nature just for safety sake and
I'm expecting to see extreme poverty but
I think there's beauty and everything I
wouldn't be surprised if they had mobile
phones and scooters and that sort of
thing so as it said that in the press
it's a city within a city they soon see
the first buildings in racine yet the
shanty town extends all the way up the
hill Wow quite quite amazing actually to
think about you've got such a poor
society living so close to a rich but
it's well worth the visit
I can't wait to walk it keep your right
keep your right tour guide marcos la la
leads the group into the heart of racine
ian and one of the numerous shopping
streets
Eileen Gerrard from Britain says not
much here reminds her of a slum very
poor conditions and I mean it's like a
very thriving busy town which is poverty
but it's this very very busy they're all
working hard amazing just a few years
ago taking pictures here would have been
life-threatening armed drug dealers
ruled the streets now for the past two
and a half years the favela has been
peaceful the local residents have got
used to large numbers of tourists here
I was privileged I think were privileged
to have them look at our favela
they have the opportunity to see a
favela from the inside how it looks how
things run and more than anything they
see that marvellous people live here the
most popular holiday snap motif and a
permanent feature of the tour is the
view from the very top it's like a
patchwork quilt all connected and in Rio
we were more than 1,000 is lungs and you
have since today some place that the
pulse don't go then is that difficult
society to balance ok is there a
solution is there a plan to to help to
change things to help all the people
with our sewage and I sometimes we ask
it but they don't have the plans because
they state now is broken so many - this
situation is very difficult ok the
complex social problems can only be
touched on that's all the tourists want
many people live here illegally and they
are the poorest of the poor
after an hour and a half their
introduction tour is over
I do I just admire them very much and I
I'm glad I don't have to live there as
Jan said we are very very privileged to
be here and visit they now plan to
recommend the favela tour to friends
back home Mumbai has one of the largest
slums in Asia
it's called Dharavi
hi my name's Steve salving I'm from
London we stopped through Mumbai for a
couple of nights and from reading the
reviews the people had said that in a
lot of cases it was the most exciting
and the most interesting thing they'd
done so whilst they were here so we
decided to give it a go phazon Farooqi
is their guide today more than 750,000
people live and work in Dharavi no one
knows the exact number even my mother if
she has enough / electro McCoy's Compton
Base she keeps on collecting it and then
she sells it or she exchange with garlic
so by doing this - we try and expel the
negative image about therapy we are when
we have beer bong water appear in her RV
this is the place where you belong and
it's it's safe and at the same time the
company provides us a part-time job so
that we can study as well as you can
look for the family
faison earns a living by doing this job
he's studying to be a pharmacist the
slum dwellers are proud of where they
live
this shop owner plans to sell his bags
under the brand name Dharavi may bother
- are they sick what or is it good for
us
there are many slums in the world but
Durov is unique because so many products
are made here so many people work here
in so many different kinds of businesses
bibo oh so I don't really think there's
a slum that's comparable to Dharavi in
that sense Medical Taniya
that I'll be using the annual turnover
in Dharavi is an estimated 600 million
euros a year the be the local tours
started back in 2010 by xiah and his
co-workers are all students his dream is
to have his own pharmacy in Dharavi one
day Steve and Lisa try an Indian snack
and of course freshly brewed tea
I think for me I really liked seeing the
way that they were recycling plastic and
I think that's because I can see people
doing that at home and our people are
throwing stuff away just treating it as
rubbish and here people are getting that
you can see all the different it little
parts of beingness through the process
so how was it do it you enjoy yeah if
you just fantastic you look good thank
you if you like it too then share your
experience with your friends and
families outside the hotel that would be
great for us Pfizer also hopes that
they'll publicize the tour on the
Internet
that's where Lisa first discovered it
good for us thank you very much you're
like appreciate it it was nice to meet
you guys all the best interest is
growing in trips like this an experience
that did not even exist a few years ago